et on termine ce journal avec le succès
du pot-au-feu géant de tour ce samedi
près de 30000 euros ont été récoltés en
faveur des Restos du Coeur années record
une opération à laquelle participait le
fils de Coluche romain Colucci mais
aussi la chanteuse Zaz marraine de cette
27e édition voyez ce reportage de
Faustine
c'est la somme récoltée par les restos
du cœur grâce au pot-au-feu géant qui se
tenait samedi dans quatre lieux de tours
soit 3% de plus qu'en 2022 au total 4720
repas ont été vendus romain Colucci le
fils de Coluche a fait le déplacement
pour l'occasion pot-au-feu géant
exceptionnel très réussi je crois qu'on
est en train de battre le record pour la
troisième année consécutive je suis très
heureux du monde qui a je suis très
heureux de la solidarité qui s'exprime
parce que bah on sait à quoi ça va
servir on sait que les besoins sont
énormes avec le succès qu'on a
aujourd'hui et le soleil c'est que du
régal un régal aussi pour les papilles
d'après les nombreux convives attabler
comme ici au bancaire j'avais envie de
manger un pot-au-feu un bon pot-au-feu
tour en Jau ce matin voilà il est
préparé avec le cœur donc il est très
bon c'est pour faire une bonne action
aussi
il y a une bonne humeur
le repas a eu tellement de succès que
des trésors les marmites étaient presque
vides
je pense que la présence de Zaz a fait a
permis d'avoir beaucoup de monde et on
en pourra pas servir tout le monde et on
n'a pas servi tout le monde en effet Zaz
marraine de cette 27e édition a fait une
apparition pour le plus grand plaisir de
ses femmes venu nombreux pour la
percevoir la chanteuse est née à
Chambray-lès-Tours et a grandi à Mettray
jusqu'à ses 9 ans
de symbolique pour moi c'est voilà les
gens connaissent pas forcément mon
histoire et voilà le fait de devenir ici
d'être marraine et de d'avoir accepté
d'être marraine bah ça c'est comme une
boucle qui est bouclée pour moi la
chanteuse n'est pas repartie sans avoir
mis l'ambiance le temps de quelques
chansons sur sa terre natale
[Musique]